our committees is draining his bathtub
every two minutes that pass seven
gallons of water are drained which of
the following functions can represent
the number of gallons of water in the
tub
w as a function of the minutes that have
passed T so let's think about this
visually so let's plot the amount the
number of gallons of water we have let's
put that in the vertical axis that is a
function of time as time passes we will
lose water at a fixed rate so this is
our time axis right over here so we're
going to start with some initial volume
of water in the tub and they actually
don't tell us what that initial volume
of water is but let's just call that
let's just call that W capital W sub
zero so this is just the initial volume
of water initial we're doing everything
in gallons so I'll say the initial
number of gallons initial number of
gallons or the number of gallons at time
equals zero this is T equals zero right
over here then they tell us that every
two minutes that pass so this is going
to time is going to be given in minutes
in minutes time is in minutes and the W
is in gallons in gallons so say every
two minutes that passed seven gallons of
water drains so let's say two minutes
pass from time equals zero so that is
one minute so this is one minute and
this is two minutes right over here so
we have two minutes passing and how much
water is going to get drained well they
tell us seven gallons of water are
drained so we're gonna after two minutes
we're gonna get to W naught minus seven
however much water we had before we're
gonna have seven gallons less W naught
minus seven is where we go and so if we
were to plot the amount of gallons or
the number of gallons we have as a
function of time it would look something
like this
it would look like a line it would look
a line look like a line that goes
something like that
so one thing that we could ask ourselves
is what is the rate of change of W with
respect to T what is the rate of change
of our vertical axis with respect to our
horizontal axis and that's also known as
the slope of our line
well the
rate of change of our so we could write
that as the rate of change this this
this this Delta symbol this Greek letter
this triangle is just shorthand for
change in so our change in W for a given
change in change in time well we know
that when time increases by two minutes
and time is in minutes W decreases by
seven gallons because it decreases its
going down and we see that this is a
downward sloping line right over here
and we see it graphically right over
here when our change in time when our
change in time is positive two our
change in time is equal to positive two
our change in our change in our change
in volume so this is this distance which
is the same thing as this distance right
over here our change in the number of
gallons is equal to negative seven so
this right over here is the slope of our
line or the rate of change of the number
of gallons with respect to time now we
don't know the exact starting position
or the exact W intercept but we just
called it W sub naught so we could write
a general equation here we could say
that the number of gallons the number of
gallons is equal to the initial gallons
that we have the initial gallons that we
have plus negative seven halves times
time or we could just call this minus
minus seven over to 7 over 2 that's just
the negative seven half right over there
times time times time and this should
make a complete sense now we have our we
have our our vertical axis intercept
often called the y-intercept but we're
not calling the y-axis them for the this
isn't called the y axis anymore we have
our vertical at intercept and we also
have the slope of our line here they're
familiar with slope intercept form we
normally write y is equal to MX plus B
where this is the slope and this is the
y-intercept we've written it the exact
same way we've said W is equal to
negative seven halves t plus W not I
just swapped these two things around
notice this is the slope and this is the
y-intercept so which of these match that
pattern well let's see I should start
with a some positive number of gallons
and I'm subtracting seven halves T so
the only one that matches this is this
one right over here is 50 is 50 minus
seven has T now even if you didn't think
anything about slopes and you were just
looking at these choices here you would
say well look I should start with a
certain get number of gallons of water
and then it should only decrease as a
number of as the amount of time passes
this one wouldn't satisfy this at time
equals zero I have no gallons here where
that doesn't meet the constraints here I
have a certain number of gallons here so
this doesn't make sense here at time
equals zero I have a hundred gallons but
then as time passes that will only
increase so this is you know this is the
the faucets on here it's not being
drained so that doesn't work here I'm
once again I'm starting with a certain
number of gallons when time equals zero
and then as time passes its increasing
my number of gallons so once again the
faucet is on right over here so once
again the only one where I'm starting
with a certain number of gallons and
then as time passes my number of gallons
are reducing because this is a negative
value is is this choice right over here